who was the last famous person you
texted besides your teammate David
Beckham what were you guys talking about
we just spoke after qar he was in qar so
just say good to see each other what is
something about F1 that would give
Americans a heart attack that you've got
to be less than 75 kilos to be an F1
driver how many speeding tickets have
you gotten in your life
probably five what is something about
Americans that you don't understand the
positivity everyone's so positive and I
love it being the passenger Prince the
what what the passenger Prince have you
ever heard of Passenger princess ah okay
no I don't you like to drive I like to
drive always I find a therapeutic